but i said well if you look at a
business actually you don't want to be
stabilizing system you want to be
unstabilized the system
because you want to grow right grow is
not stabilizing
[Music]
professor edison say nice to uh nice to
have you here on 20 minute leaders
thank you yeah nice to talk to you here
yeah thank you so i've had the unique
pleasure of being in your class most
recently at stanford
and the masters in management and
engineering and msmb274
and you're a world expert on on your
product management thinking
strategically about
entrepreneurial strategy the inventor of
the grabber holder dynamics strategy and
i'd love to spend these next 20 minutes
you sort of picking your brain and
trying to consolidate
some of what we've learned over the past
10 weeks it's going to be an impossible
feat
but we'll try as much as we can so can
you just start tell me a little bit
about yourself how did you even get
to this you know incredible incredible
industry
okay uh well starting a little bit
myself you know i'm
actually uh my trainer is electric
engineering
so i got a phd in electric engineering
from mit
so my area is actually in system and
control
and i've been doing a lot of work in
there and getting some
awards and things like that but i'm sort
of start
interested in something you know when i
do this
system and control they're all man-made
right system things like that right
but i'm starting interest in you know
you know
system where you have a lot of human a
lot of people
right so i start
to uh work in the industry for many
years
and then it's like coming back to
stanford but going not to the electrical
engineering department
but going into beginning is the
engineering economic systems where we're
looking at
systems uh can be human system
can be you know it's a combination of
human system and
the engineering system so we believe
that it's the interaction of all the
system
that makes into it and i'm also
interested in some of the economics
aspect of it so that's how i get started
and
do some work uh in um as for example
uh managing fisheries and some of the
natural resources and things like that
but i guess interested in in business
because i got
you know my ex boss you know
asked me to uh to join his company
uh we started a company but i was uh but
i was a
faculty member so i say i won't i can't
join the company you were already where
were your faculty member at stanford
yeah i was a faculty stanford
and so i said i'm you know i would not
be able to join a company but he said
well you don't have to join a company
let me say
well you can be a consultant right right
so to be a consultant to be a co-founder
as
a consultant i say well just interesting
road so i
get into it so we built a company which
is uh in the very beginning it's
actually the old company
in the first wave of ai we're doing some
more work in there
okay so it's a more technology driven
and we do a lot of technology work and
things like that
but i started because i was uh i played
a role
as not only a consultant i was on the
board so i could start
understanding on what's happening in the
business world
so that i get interested in the
entrepreneurship
part of it so i was doing you know and
then i come back to stand you know i
and then i still want to continue doing
work at stanford
so i start my interest my interest has
shifted
because of that from a little bit of
economics and go
into the business world business and
that's how it gets started okay right
and
in the very beginning my my research
more on the
system part for sort of looking at
business as
an overall system interesting so
thinking from the system point of view
how the system point of view looking
from the business
organization right you can think of
system organization really a system
so that's the electrical engineer part
of you that's that's trying to
business as another yeah and then you
know that's
in engineering you know the engineering
big thing in engineering especially in
control is feedback right
feedback control is a big thing um but
the feedback control is always you try
to stabilize the system
right but i said well if you look at a
business
actually you don't want to be
stabilizing system you want to be
unstabilized the system
because you want to grow right grow is
not stabilizing
so what what you what i'm saying that
actually in business what you need is
not negative feedback you're not
positive feedback
so that's a that's a whole concept of
where to come in so what is a positive
feedback
right i possibly think that is something
that excites you
and then you have something supporting
you and then you create
a exponential growth that's that's where
from
the you know sort of uh engineering
point of view
right and so so you know i i i'm very
curious about this the grabber holder
dynamics which you know we've
we've talked about extensively over the
past 10 weeks right and and i think it's
fascinating how it defines
so much of also what we're seeing now
you know covet is taking is
has taken over and a lot of what i'm
seeing now in the way that companies are
approaching this
and a lot of the innovations that are
coming about i keep trying to classify
them how are they
strategizing and positioning themselves
within these gruber holder dynamics so
could you give us
a slight introduction into what what is
this dynamic that
that is now so popular right so so how
do you create a positive dynamic
right to be able to cause a dynamic
from the engineering term is that you
are creating an eigenvalue was positive
in some way so it's from the
mathematical point of view but
how do you translate it into the
business point of view i say it must be
something
that sort of didn't let you fall down
right if it's something that
you follow so what you want to do is
that
your business you're going to grab it
you're going to you're not going to
excite it in certain way and then you're
going to find something to hold it and
that's how that
grabber holding come along and one of
the disruption
is that there are forces that sort of
creating forces
that could you kick you in a certain
direction right it's a huge force
so what you can do using a rubber holder
dynamic so you can think of all those
forces like
i like grabber right they're actually
you're pushing you in a certain
direction
but it will you know but it will not
stay there because
when the forces go away you know you'll
fall down but if you can fall
if you can hold it then then you create
a new
situation so i'm saying for example if
you take the covert situation
yeah the code situation actually are a
sort of a kick you
uh in a certain way so that you shifted
your preference you shifted your way
of what is the right way of doing things
and sometimes it may allow you
to create um a different kind
of uh value structure for example
a lot of people find that because of
this covet 19 right
people actually find new value in family
they revisit the value of family they
revisit the value of
community right which they have lost
you know they're too busy they lost it
now they sort of now they have something
but then in order for that to sustain
that means that if you can have
something that hold it
then it become even that the the coveted
is gone
you still have this this this value just
say sustaining
but the question is what are those
things you need to build up so that you
can support it right so what you're
saying is that the grabber
the the way that the grabbing works is
sort of like a kick in the stomach and
okay we're shifting the consumer
behavior in one way whether it's an
invention or if it's a global pandemic
exactly
and we and now now we've attained this
new behavior we've shifted the consumers
have shifted the mindset the values
their desires etc now the question is
how do we
hold or retain these contain that so if
you you couldn't
retain it then we'll bounce it back
right so a good case of this would be
well so zoom for example enjoyed a lot
of this new type of consumer interaction
and a lot of people are wondering well
now things are opening starting to open
up again hopefully soon everything will
open up
and are we retaining this consumer
behavior
virtually also for example if zoom can
do something
to make you feel that even you're back
to normal life
you still find new value in there and
then
if i can build certain things that
that's what i call the holder right so
the holder
is something you build afterwards after
you see where the
the the grabber is is pushing you
so so building the holder is more like
um
you know you do it in time uh it's not
something that you can foresee
so you just have to play around it's
more adaptive if it's more
you know you have to build up as you go
on that's that's the whole concept right
so what are some examples of grabber
holder dynamics that that we can see
over the past i don't know half a
century for example well there's a lot
well
i mean almost everything is sort of like
you start have a grabber
and then you start having a holder i'll
give you a few
um sort of example right um
the um you know for example um
take pc exam we talk about pc right yeah
pc is a typical grabber and holder
dynamic concept right
the the idea is that i'm going to have a
computer for everybody this
sounds a great idea okay essentially in
the beginning
nobody know what what does that mean i
just yeah they know what's a computer
right they know a little bit about
computer you know the main frame is do a
lot of calculation
but it's too complicated two big things
right too many things right
and if you ask them what is needed and
nobody knows right so in the very
beginning you see what the computer is
it's a little box
they can do a calculation and then
sometimes when you turn off the
electricity everything is gone right
that is oh wow
that's not good right so it's exciting i
can use that to make calculation
but all the calculations that i make is
all gone
that's in the very beginning the first
pc doesn't have a memory
interesting okay so what they did they
do they they attach
a uh a uh a recorder tape recorder
you know uh they like like like the you
know the
regular tape recorder attached to the pc
so that you can record it
it's but then then you have the search
rules so
it's very complicated right and that's
why they're going at this time right
this right comes in
because they see a need that if i do all
the computation where i'm going to put
it
right we know that a big computer they
can do it but when you're a little boxer
you say personal computer i'm so small
should i have it or not nobody know in
the very beginning so
sort of trying errors and and you may
say that the first success of
apple ii is because they attached to it
with the disk drive
okay okay so was that the
perspective of it that's the whole
perspective no no you need this right
they people find you near this right
well also you need to have some
computational
tool because if you're a computer you
know no one is going to do a writer
programming
and at that time apple 2 becomes
successful is mainly because
then the west star and
vcal comes in that allows you to do word
processing
type a letter and things like that visit
cal allow you to do simple
you know calculation and you know
accounting
and that's when being successful and
that's the holder right
definitely okay so you have said that
you have that example and i'd love to
talk
also about a retail and that
specifically i'm interested because that
was my
that was i'll give you another very
interesting example right yeah please
okay the other interesting example is
alibaba
okay yeah very relevant yes okay now
started off you know i mean he would
they would alibaba start fooling around
with uh
with the internet but in the very
beginning
uh they are helping american firm to
source
uh product in china that's that's how
they do it right
it's more like a b2b right they're
sourcing they're helping you
actually they're not helping you to
source it they get they you just go in
and find information okay you want to
buy certain things
i can tell you you know who are the
manufacturers yeah
that's that's they started in the very
beginning okay let me
keep it going wrong okay and then
then amazon started in u.s and sort of
the e-commerce can't start in u.s and
they are successful and e-commerce and
and ebay they all come to go to china
want to do it in china
the alibaba said wow i can do that too
right you know it's sort of a similar
thing
and maybe i should also set up something
like this
okay but on the other hand
one other thing is that if you want to
do e-commerce right
so what is a holder what is the holder
where's the holder right
one is that why would people want to
come to
the you know to to the computer the buy
thing is that a normal thing that people
do
right no the answer is no yeah maybe
some young kid
back then it wasn't right yeah not at
that time right let me use something
young kid without trying not only that
not everybody has computer in china
right okay so so so when i said where's
the holder right so the holder is that
you need to have a computer you have
someone you need to have a computer
right but on the other hand uh also what
you need is that how are you gonna pay
okay right and then the third is that
how do i trust you
you know why do i want to buy it in
there because if i buy something
it's not useful then what what right
yeah now in u.s you know it becomes
take off for several reasons i think the
holder is there
okay and you in us how do you solve the
problem of payment well you can have
you know credit card scan your credit
card whatever
even though they have paypal but they
started off with credit cards so people
can pay credit card
right so that solved the problem of
payment
uh well how do i trust it well in u.s
they have the
consumer protection u.s a very high
consumer protection so that if you don't
like it you can return it
yeah okay then you have to accept the
return okay
so that means that in the u.s the the
holder is there
right okay but but professor it sounds
also that
but in china is not there yeah so so it
sounds that in order for
a company like ebay or amazon to become
a holder
of this new user experience you need
your they they were you need to deal
with the two problems right
and they didn't deal with them on their
own they had the government
and the payment system uh deal with them
for them right they didn't do this
but because that means that the us all
have already infrastructure
right are you to do it and sometimes
people have a term that you
in china you know in developing
countries sometimes they give a term
called institutional void
there's some institutional void and
that's exactly what happened in china
that's an institutional void in china
the credit card system there's no credit
ranking system
right that's more you know sort of
credit you know assessment system
so therefore you cannot you don't know
so there's not a lot of credit card
you're sending around
and most of the credit cards they sent
around in china are all those very
famous
uh you know millionaire right sure but
yeah young you know young people they
will not
have one right right so the rich people
in china they're not going to buy things
on themselves you know on their own so
then they're not the shopper
so they have the credit card another
shopper right the shopper the one they
didn't have to credit content
so also when you when you talk about
timing how timing is important for a
startup or for any entrepreneur exactly
you have to know the situation over
there right
so the other thing yeah there you go so
the other thing is that
this trust problem right because
in china if you buy certain things if
you don't like it you cannot return it
okay people will not return it and they
will not accept it
and there's no law to sort of to protect
you
okay so you cannot sue them or whatever
you cannot do that
so therefore how do you solve that
problem okay
and this is how you know um
alibaba becomes successful so how do
they solve it
how do they solve it okay the way they
solve it say we're gonna set up
something called
like an escrow system you know like u.s
area the escrow system
well the escrow system is that you buy
certain things
right uh you know a certain amount you
pay
into um alibaba okay alibaba is going to
be
like an escrow they're going to hold it
they're not going to release it to the
to the seller and then they tell the
seller that the buyer have already paid
and you can ship it to him right okay
and they ship it to the the
the buyer and the buyer have seven days
to see
to examine the thing and within seven
days they can return it
to alibaba and alibaba will ship it back
to the seller
and return the money back to the buyer
so that means that they are the
middleman
to keep track on that right that's a lot
of logistics to sell
a lot of logistics to do right and not
only that they say no
no fee no fee no fee
so that means that if you return you
know doesn't cost you anything
interesting and you know i think that
you know so that obviously is very
so an amazon it's different because you
actually pay
in advance you already pay for the
product but you have so much
trust in the system that you know you
can just return it
right two things because in the credit
card system
if you don't like it you can complain to
the credit card and credit card can we
hold it
but what is interesting is that that's
already set up in u.s
right right but you and then you have a
platform like upwork which is for
freelancers
where you actually keep the money in
escrow it's all
you know virtual there's no tangible
services it's all
hypothetical uh work to be done like
please put in data like do a research
project for me
not that i would ever do that first
effort of course but then
once i put the money in escrow the
freelancer can perform the work
and only once i am satisfied the money
gets released
which leaves room for negotiation
because it's so subjective on what are
the goods
and what are the quality of the goods
that's exactly what's happening right
so this is exactly what alibaba did but
they i think they the interesting part
what they did
is that you you know i charge it free
then you say you know what you know
where do they make my money
there's an interesting part the seventh
day where the money is
in alibaba he would put it into
the money market and earn something
and that's how they pay for it this is
this is in the gray area right yeah
because it's not your money
right yeah it's not your money right but
then if you have a lot of money coming
in
then you can become a pile but then they
very quickly
shift into set up another thing called
you know extra money account that means
that i can put money in there
and uh you know the money would be used
for
helping you you know would make the
interest for you
and they keep a little bit and then
every time you buy thing you can use
that money so they solve the problem
very quickly
after a while so they use a gray area to
move in
okay so that's the part they solve that
that
holder but there's another great holder
is very important is why
would people buy things on the internet
okay now it turns out if you look at the
timing it turns out
they start taking off in year 2003
okay what is the significance you
in year 2003 saars appear in china
like the covert 19. because of size
many places are in lockdown especially
in beijing
okay technology into it and then now
people still have to buy thing what do
they do
they go to the internet i love it okay
now whether whether without that that
will happen or not i don't know
because you know history didn't tell us
i mean i cannot run back the history
but i can say that has something to do
with it because it helped
to change people's preference in buying
so as i'm saying that's why i'm talking
they're talking to you guys that in
covet 19
we have a lot of things going to happen
if you
learn from the alibaba example that
means that there are new things going to
open up
if you can see what it's leading to and
that's that's actually
that's another company called jd it's
actually
that company jd it started off is that
he is
only a um he have a retail store
selling electronic in beijing
and because of sars he actually moved it
into the india no no it means that
there's certainly something that
happening there
is now the lot one of the largest uh
e-commerce in china now
it's no no it's unbelievable and jack
ma's story aside from all that is just
you know so phenomenal by itself and i
think what's really really incredible
and and very reflective on what we've
done over this past 10 weeks it's
understanding
how dynamic this world is and how as an
entrepreneur you could have an amazing
idea with amazing execution but if
you're not dynamic and if you're not
thinking about market forces and how
everything is changing
then you're not you're not setting
yourself up for success and
especially today with things changing so
fast you know just i just heard a
podcast that
instacart the the shopping the grocery
shopping application
they've reached their financial
milestone that they predicted for 2024.
now you would think that in 2020 with
like you know so many smart people
working on this billion dollar company
they'd be able to predict
their sales over years and it just shows
how you know something happens to the
world the markets shift consumers shift
who would have guessed that they would
have had you know
year or four years advancement in just
you know a matter of weeks
i can't believe our time is almost up
and professor i know you have to go to
your next meeting already
but i have to leave with one last
question three words
that you would best describe yourself or
any of your colleagues at stanford would
they
would describe you as well i don't know
um i i think the hardest question
hardest questions right right i
i think that um
[Music]
i would like to uh you know my interest
my desire is to um
yeah three things right i feel that
entrepreneur
is a um is culturally dependent
okay in different parts of the world you
have a different kind of
entrepreneurial activity a different
kind of innovation
but the innovation are culturally
dependent so that means that whatever
uh and and each country you know each
part of the world with their
cultural background they have actually a
different competitive advantage in
deriving certain type of innovation
and so i believe that you know people
should collaborate
worldwide collaboration and innovation
and take the past in this part
and the whole idea that you know
innovation is
creating value to the world so maybe i
would
like to describe me as like to promote
uh creation i like to promote global
innovation
to um to increase the
the well-being you know the likelihood
of everybody in the world i love it so
much professor
thank you so much for your time and i
think it'll take one and three words
i'll i'll take it because it was just
too inspiring professor thank you for
the last time okay
right thank you for the thank you for it
for teaching us all
about dynamic entrepreneurial strategy
and i look forward to taking more
classes with you
okay great i'll see you take care bye
you